let's go to Gabriel from Albany New York
Gabriel welcome
it's going well good
um
question because in I live in a live in
New York yep and as you know this is a
pretty rural Republican area oh yeah um
at least in the more rural aspects but
there's a lot of people in my
surrounding circles that I've considered
like kind and especially intelligent
people as long as I've known them
um who have really Fallen prey to a lot
of the current rhetoric surrounding the
Republican party yes what do you think
really changed in the past probably 10
years because they often spout as an
example of why they don't trust the
government as like oh I'm you know as
you grow older you you just see that you
don't trust the government more
why do you think there's been such a
massive distrusting government
that makes people just like from
skeptical to like completely
conspiratorial there has been an overt
campaign from the right to say you can't
trust the government you shouldn't trust
the government the government can't be
trusted and of course as most reasonable
people know there are certain things
that it makes total sense to have
governments involved in and there are
other areas where it's perfectly fine to
let basically markets allocate direct
the allocation of resources but
it's been the following combination if
we zoom out is what I would say
declining education
partisan media
filter Bubbles and Echo chambers that
are self-reinforcing on social media
and a complete abandonment of policy by
the American right wing
and a replacement with exactly the types
of bullet points and talking points that
you're talking about
in some total that's a lot working
against us
now look that makes sense yeah all right
Gabriel from Albany thank you very much
for the call we're just hearing from a
few people we had a guest cancellation
and it lets us get on the phone and hear
from a variety of of great people let's
go to Eric from Long Island Eric welcome
to the show what's on your mind today oh
hi David how's it going it's going well
yeah so um uh thanks for doing this last
minute I suppose uh I didn't have too
much to say today but I'm sure you saw
the news about uh uh how Clarence Thomas
is starting to cover for uh Lindsey
Graham and Georgia did you have any
thing you wanted to say about that or is
that good covered it's the top story on
today's show which of course you
wouldn't know because you are on today's
show right now and it becomes sort of
this uh endless feedback loop uh no
listen
Clarence Thomas's wife
is an election denier
a January 6th adjacent individual in
touch with all sorts of players in the
Insurrection and the riots and like I
said at the top of the show I won't
repeat myself fully but he should have
nothing to do with any legal decisions
even remotely connected to the November
of 2020 election it's insane that he
does
absolutely yeah and it's it's actually
quite frightening how they're they're
they're actually doing all this in broad
daylight and it doesn't it seems like
there's not much we can do about it it
feels like there's very little we can do
about it that's for sure yeah yeah all
right all right my friend David thank
you very much appreciate that